[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu veux que je dis
génial d'avoir une seconde est en train
de décrire le futur technologique en
étant sensation de toucher partout au
multi matériaux
oui on est vraiment dans ce que nous on
appelle un habitué
vous avez carrément à l'intérieur du
bois un écran cet acte il
[Musique]
on continue aujourd'hui sur ce qu'on
voyait tout cool je vais traîner un peu
du côté de l'eurêka parc
je pense qu'il ya des trucs super
intéressante à voir côté french tech
on va voir un peu ce que ça a donné
cette année au niveau de la fraîcheur
qui avait un vrai regroupement des
régions nos chances un truc hyper hyper
cool il ya des techno qui vont nous lier
très intéressante à voir en une
j'ai vraiment envie de vous parler j'ai
déjà intérêts donc j'ai regardé tout ça
et puis voilà on continue demain départ
pour new york j'ai passé deux jours à
new york c'est sur trois et un petit peu
votre arrivée en france parce que la m
avec à la journée de 9 heures donc voilà
donc ça c'est un peu le le programme de
la journée
il est là il est venu là bim altimate
gmail un monde connecté pour les
infortunes attavanti m toujours avec
voir l'amour ça l'est vraiment j'ai fait
du sport le scao et les places que les
paroles de jeu ouais quand même
direct c'est le top et là tu vas où
l'appétit leur vie vraiment pas ce
cadeau c'est fatiguant comme excuse
coller des trucs ses fans
elles veulent tout l'argent et l'envoyer
vidal cherchait des affaires peu oublié
non je ne savais pas que je devais
pousser pour la télé américaine aux
châtaignes et du coup d'écouté
j'ai besoin de ma tenue de super super
héros aux joueurs d'une entreprise qui
pour moi est un l'initiative de cas au
début d'une vraie révolution
pour les smartphones mais pas que les
smartphones c'est une autre cause les
voitures complètement victimes c'est
vraiment génial j'ai déjà vu l'an
dernier j'étais très contente pour
l'instant de les entraîner à las vegas
pourtant son nom de grenoble j'aurais pu
faire moins de chemin pour aller les
voir mais bon quand on aime on ne compte
pas et franchement leur solution est
vraiment révolutionnaire va changer
beaucoup de choses
vous allez voir c'est complètement
hallucinant je regarde soit là sans moi
ok voilà et on reste dans le cas donc
bouge pas trop les camps pour mériter un
cédric de la société a plu à tout
doucement la société exactement
s'annonce société satori dernières
rencontres et abdou diouf au cs aussi
avec gaza lors c'est un tout qui est
complètement hallucinant c'est à dire
c'est toucher un clic sur l'écran c'est
ça exactement on vient rajouter cette
troisième dimension qui manque
aujourd'hui à nos écrans et celle du
toucher et l'idée c'est de rendre usage
de nos smartphones par exemple beaucoup
plus immersive
on part de smartphones mais on peut
choisir n'importe quel cliché sur un
écran moi même au delà d'un écran parle
donc d'une interface tactile et d'une
surface entre utiliser des micros
composants qui viennent générer une
micro vibrations d'accord dans cette
micro vibrations
ll va faire en sorte que tu va se sentir
comme de la texture et du relief son
tournoi
d'accord et de manière complètement
interactive cercle t'imagines le l'image
d'un écran de changer la couleur du
petit léo nous ont bien transposer ça
qu'on devient du toucher et aucun
endroit tu vas voir un bouton 1
autrement tu pas une molette un
troisième endroit tu vas voir un curseur
ça devient du logiciel du soft
typiquement regarder en démo on a une
surface d'aluminium donc là on le
regarde comme ça très clairement il n'y
a absolument aucun relief absolument
rien l'âge et les vibrations seront plus
en plus forte
là on est sur une touche et vers l'idée
c'est tout va effectivement sentir ce
qu'on va sentir sur une plaque
vitrocéramique pour la cuisine je veux
faire du café
là je sens crantage c'était tac
que rien
tak tak
donc là ça interagit directement il faut
imaginer que le doit en quelque sorte on
fait surfer au dessus de l'écran et puis
tu sais il ya des gens qui font du ski
wakeboard c'est utile ans une planche et
puis tu as tenté une fine pellicule
d'eau entre la planche et le sable tout
va bien ouais hutues sauf lorsque l'eau
se retire la planche rentrer en contact
avec le sable et là tu tombes et bien
c'est ce qu'on ferme ton doigt ton doigt
il va surfer habitants un coup on va
arrêter la vibration et là le doivent
être bloqués ce qu'on fait à très haute
fréquence et c'est ce qui te donne cette
illusion parce que c'est quand même en
train de toucher du verre cette illusion
d'avoir de la texture et du relief sur
ton écran
alors là ça ateliers plastiques on est
sur l'automobile donc là on va régler le
rétroviseur je sens plein de petites ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta se doit ce
pilote mon rétroviseur que je vais
monter descendre à droite à gauche et
maintenant je peux me baisser les vitres
up deux fois que les deux doigts en bas
j'ai baissé les vitres de douar aux jo
remonte l'élite c'est hallucinant la
sensation sous les doigts maintenant à
s'attaquer aux bois on peut allumer la
lumière et on peut changer la couleur
enfin j'ai un grand écran moi c'est
vraiment le hall of là j'allume j'éteins
en la maintenant se tourner pour changer
la la lumière sur place à 100 sous le
doigt fans petit chantage l'objectif
c'est vraiment de rendre l'utilisation
des interfaces tactiles et tu vois
qu'elles sont maintenant
dans notre quotidien beaucoup plus
immersif alors une des applications
auxquelles on pense c'est tout ce qui
est équipements électroménagers on voit
que de plus en plus maintenant dans les
frigos on va voir et bien des écrans
tactiles ou même des interfaces tactiles
et bien là l'idée ce serait de rajouter
la possibilité de paramétrer la
température de son
appareils électroménagers mes enfants
tant physiquement comme si on avait une
vraie molette est un vrai bouton son
doigt là j'ai vraiment la sensation du
bouton qui bouge
je me sens vraiment en fonction d'écran
un cran hop là hop hop c'est pas du tout
la même sensation entre un bouton et
l'autre là je sens vraiment le cran et
là c'est plus continue c'est beaucoup
plus doux et là c'est vachement plus dur
est à ta ta ta ta ta ta playa - cran la
spouze espacées et là il ya un côté
vachement plus rugueux au niveau du
toucher très simplement c'est à la fois
immersive et interactive est totalement
contribuera donc tu fais ce que tu veux
c'est hallucinant tu pas
d'électroménager ont fait part les
automobiles oui alors l'automobile
là il ya un vrai enjeu de sécurité
routière parce qu'il faut imaginer
malheureusement que l'utilisation des
écrans
dans la voiture je pense pas pas
simplement du smartphone mais les écoles
sont maintenant dans les tableaux de
voir systématiquement et bien c'est un
élément de distraction finalement à la
conduite et
la problématique c'est comment tu viens
donner une information en temps réel aux
conducteurs alors qu'il est censé garder
la route sur les yeux c'est là où
intervient notre technologie puisque à
nouveau il va pouvoir et bien sentir le
réglage de la température le réglage de
la clim de multimédia et autres par le
biais du touch et qui peut garder les
yeux sur la route et en même temps ils
contrôlent de manière interactive sont
donc n'a même plus besoin de regarder du
sens que tu fais et voilà il est en plus
c'est beaucoup plus sécurisé donc ça
veut dire que tu vas voir des voitures
sans doute au foot alors à terme on peut
imaginer ça a nagé un tableau de bord
complètement dégagée sur les portières
complètement dégagée que rien juste des
zones délimitées ou du retour actif
si tu va visiter les stands des grands
fabricants d'automobiles je pense
notamment à mercedes tu vois que tout
l'habitacle devient tactile
voilà c'est une tendance irréversible
clairement et c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'intéressent à des technologies comme
un autre parce que il ya besoin en même
temps de
de rendre tangible ou est-ce que
plus on va être avant tu avais les
autoradios avec le bouton qu'une heure
et autres ont ça ça a disparu et l'écran
est très
incontournable maintenant mais il faut
redonner à l'utilisateur cette notion
d'interaction tangibles pour des
questions de sécurité
non seulement tu peux tout paramétrer
dans le
du tac mais qui doit encore se dire que
tu n'as plus forcément besoin d'un écran
se dire que il ya des matériaux qui sont
quand même intéressant a privilégié
parce qu'ils sont très qualitative je
pense notamment aux bois tu vois d'avoir
des portières couvert de plaques et de
bois sur la portière et à l'intérieur
duquel on va mettre des curateurs à coup
sûr que ça va très très bien sûr que
c'est plus simplement l'écran c'est
n'importe quelle surface dans ta voix du
multi matériaux multi matériaux et
interactions tangible ici on a un
exemple de ce qui pourrait être aussi
sur un smartphone l'intérêt d'atypique
c'est de venir ajouter des nouvelles
fonctions des nouveaux usages vous
regarde par exemple je repose on doit la
pêche peut naviguer sans jamais dans les
doigts
donc je sais que je suis grâce à
l'activité
je sais je suis là et cetera tu peux
changer avec un seul point comme vous le
savez les écrans de smartphones il lui
faut plus long maintenant il faut que
demain on va pas bientôt 3 pourquoi
retourner en même temps là l'avantagé
quelques un seul doigt j'ai beaucoup
vu que j'ai aussi toujours pareil des
informations de la sens du toucher
je pas obligés de regarder donc ces
contrôles là je peux les pertes depuis
ma poche je voulais faire ailleurs j'ai
juste besoin d'un doigt et ne pas
regarder mon écran bon d'accord
donc ça va plus vite c'est beaucoup plus
intuitif alors nous on travaille à la
fois avec des fabricants et de
smartphones et de voitures pour leur
permettre de tester une technologie dans
des situations réelles fabriqué avec ont
travaillé de très très grands noms dans
l'automobile peut malheureusement pas
forcément si ténu en corrèze où vit
l'ancien est évidente mais les plus
vivants l'accord est plus grand et puis
en même temps on travaille en amont sur
l'intégration des technologies parce que
à terme il faudra que la technologie
soit intégrée dans l'écran ou dans
l'interface tactile
quelle qu'elle soit et ça c'est notre
mission également donc on a développé
une technologie qui est extrêmement
miniaturisés
deux micros
m 2007 épaisseur c'est extrêmement fin
et donc elle sera directement sous
l'écran bon toi extérieurement tu verras
rien craindre un second écran est tout
ce qu on sera quand on coupe des
géniales et les remparts les tares de
smartphones tu me parles bien de choses
avec les doigts du smartphone qui est
intéressant avec altran technologies
apple you c'est que tu peux
véritablement offrir de nouveaux modes
d'utilisation cerqueux ya un problème
tout bête lorsqu'on vient toucher un
écran c'est qu'automatiquement la main
bien caché une partie l'écran voilà non
là je suis sur mon écran
j'ai touché n'a effectivement jamais
caché le camouflage est exactement là
c'est de l'information que tu perds oui
alors l'idée ça doit être de mettre un
espèce de trackpad tactile
l'interface tactile au dos du smartphone
le problème c'est que dans ce cas là tu
vas passer du temps à chercher le
pointeur chercher le tournoi sauf si
elle veut que tu as du retour tactile
directement intégrés ou là tu vas
directement sentir et bien est ce que tu
es sûr qu'à l'icône surtout
conte applications principales est ce
que tu es en train de contrôler à
molette voilà ça veut dire que tout bon
smartphone comme ça j'aurai je pourrais
avoir en tout cas une zone tactile avec
le retour haptique parler c'est vraiment
d'avoir face à moi le visuel et au dos
une façon de naviguer qui est
complètement intuitive parce que je me
sens exactement ce qui se passe sur nos
dépenses on exactement ça
qu'est ce que tu veux que je dise
génial encore une grande dette en train
de décrire le futur technologique en
étant sensation de toucher partout en
multi matériaux
oui on est vraiment dans ce que nous on
appelle l'intelligence sensorielle c'est
ouvrir un nouveau canal de communication
aujourd'hui on est beaucoup sur la
vision mais finalement le centre touché
c'est un canal de communication qui est
résumant et qui permet pourtant de
communiquer des informations de manière
directe et très intuitive d'accord tu es
dans un environnement bruyant comme
comme ici eh bien s'ils jouaient
certains d'attirer l'attention
je vais mettre la main sur ton épaule
est automatiquement tout va me regarder
alors que si je t'appelle tu vas pas
forcément mon temps voilà vraiment qui
est resté dans la roue est rappelé fort
à propos pour moi vous êtes vraiment en
train de révolutionner tout ce marché là
même celle multimarchés donc vous êtes
vraiment
start up de grenoble qui révolutionne le
marché tactile internationale on a des
ambitions qui sont énormes imaginez
c'est parce qu'on apporte une troisième
dimension et qu'on est convaincu que ça
va bouleverser la façon dont moody's
nous atteint fertile et noé contact je
sens les écailles
c'est ouf enfin je suis sur un écran ou
en fait il ya absolument rien et ce sont
vraiment le relief et nageoires away
juste trophée la gêne aux textures sur
l'oeil c'est un truc assez bizarre
effectivement ce groupement d'hommes qui
est vraiment intéressant donc une
solution
atik comme celle de abstenus c'est
vraiment une vision aussi ré à l'avenir
se projeter dans le futur même si une
technique existe actuellement mais qui
est en train de se développer se
projeter dans le futur surtout les
usages multi matériaux
l'année dernière j'ai des rencontres et
ont parlé effectivement que d'écran
aujourd'hui on peut le faire sans
n'importe quel matériau sorelois sort de
là lui sur ce qu'on veut donc ça c'est
vraiment hyper intéressant est ce qu'on
voit c'est vraiment enlever tous les
boutons je dirais les boutons classiques
c'est tout un peu moche dans
l'automobile ajouté uniquement des
petites interface qu'on va pouvoir
mettre en place et moi ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant est ce que vous
voyez les usages et est-ce qu'au final
vous avez hâte que cette techno arrive
chez vous on a un autre qui est
complètement fou furieux
vous avez carrément à l'intérieur du
bois un écran cet acte il s'est
complètement
tus tomizawa et vous pouvez le lier en
plus avec google assistant donc voulu
poser des questions il m'a l'affiché
dessus et vous un truc est vraiment
vraiment vraiment incroyable gardez vous
pouvez par exemple régler ici la
luminosité de la cuisine vous avez la
température vous pouvez régler dans
votre intérieur vous avez pas mal de
choses donc là on voit que en plus du
toucher à petit qu'on peut retrouver
dans les communes solutions comme alto
you on peut vraiment intégré en plus des
écrans fin en tout cas aussi vraiment un
écran mais en tout cas de l'affichage
dans des matériaux nobles comme le bois
et c'est franchement impressionnant
alors là vous avez l'air frais comme des
gardons et java ça se passe bien on a
dormi très longtemps au lieu de +2 du
coup c'est pour ça que là tu es en train
de
la vitamine vitamines petites amies et
amis weir coiffe toi low cost alors
maxime maxime business france comment ça
s'est passé cette année
business france 24 vous prendrez la joue
intéressant mais en fait la french tech
que tu l'as vu on
on était extrêmement nombreux cette
année et au lieu d'avoir des français un
peu partout on s'est tous mis sous les
mêmes couleurs les couleurs de l'as
fabrègues donc avec sa coque rouge
tous les visiteurs étrangers commencent
à être connaître et donc l'année
dernière la french tech qu'il y avait à
les quarante stands 42 même de mémoire
d'accord cette année on arrive 170 160
distance
1200 m² de french state d'intérêt y met
la tête surtout les français en fait ça
veut dire qu'il ya eu un regroupement
des régions
au début c'était french business france
vous étiez vraiment
vous avec le coq rouge et enfin les
autres régions est un peu éparpillé
laver les régions un petit peu partout
donc quand un éditeur américain est déjà
de placer la france c'est vrai évident
alors si tu lui demandes en plus j'avais
placé
toulouse qui a monté en haut tu la perds
du lycée mort on a réussi à fédérer les
neuf régions sur onze ex présente c'est
cool c'est pas mal ça nous laisse un
petit challenge pour l'année prochaine
mais
il y arriver petit à petit et il importe
en fait c'est moi il ya forcément un peu
de politique
tu t'en doutes mais l'important c'est
que l'entrepreneur le starter qui expose
qui vient faire son business
on devrait
au moins là il peut réussir à vendre sa
solution à elle proposé à plein de
journalistes
ces faits lui qui compte non travail
pour lui que sur ses pales inverse
c'est très très important moi tant qu'on
continue à voir ces ces start peur qui
ont de belles idées et qui cartonne à
travers le monde
là on a un bracelet alors un bracelet
qui est bien plus qu'un bracelet car
était une application qui est là
vraiment pour alerter pour la violence
faite aux femmes et pour la violence en
règle générale c'est un bracelet
collecter qu'on pourrait penser tout ce
qui est plus simple en réalité c'est
bien plus intéressant que ça c'est un
bouton poussoir donc vous boucher dessus
sans une alerte dans votre smartphone
est aussi dans le smartphone de trois
personnes avouent qu'ils sont des
contacts privilégiés
l'idée si vous voulez c'est
d'enregistrer ce qui se passe vous êtes
agressé vous avez un problème vous êtes
géolocaliser les personnes qui sont
contactés savent exactement où vous êtes
et là ils peuvent décider de vous
contacter d'appeler les secours porte
assistance en ça c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressant alors c'était par le
bracelet le plus texte est pas une
ovation l'habitacle du crs mais
franchement c'est un vrai sens et ça
pour coup franchement c'est génial petit
trimaran on a une brosse à dents qui
vous permet de vous brosser les dents en
10 secondes en fait vous mettez votre
dentifrice vouloir s'arrêter dans votre
bouche vous laisser appuyé ici ça vous
fait des micro vibrations cinq secondes
en os 5 secondes en bas et hop les dans
son brossage est suffisant c'est bon
pour lutter contre la plaque dentaire
tout ce que vous voulez c'est vraiment
pratique à la société succès qui est
basé à lyon ça paye why broches pour
l'instant c'est pas un produit qui est
dispo qui va l'être très bientôt en tout
cas c'est vraiment sympa
e
voilà c'est la fin de notre cité en mars
et pour 2000 vols cs du 7 au 10 janvier
à légal ou pas congédier vidéo tu as
accès à tout le monde
puis on voit que le stand de la french
tech ouais jusqu'à que quand mon bureau
en fait c'était très bien bravo monsieur
belle performance tchèque qui s'est
passé est un problème c'est très
technique là c'est la peine qu'a fait la
technologie protégée la marsa le
français